merci monsieur le premier ministre la
parole et à madame marie-christine
dalloz
merci monsieur le président j'aurais
d'abord une pensée pour les enfants
les salariés de l'entreprise logo mais
dans le jura mise en ce matin en
liquidation judiciaire à effet immédiat
monsieur le premier ministre pourquoi en
fin de mandature
voulez vous vous obstinez à mettre en
place de prélèvement à la source est
électoraliste
cette mesure s'appliquerait au 1er
janvier 2018 votre gouvernement répète
sans cesse que un grand nombre de prêts
de pays pratiquent déjà le prélèvement à
la source
certes mais vous oubliez trop vite que
notre système fiscal n'est comparable à
aucun autre pays à celui d'aucun autre
pays
l'impôt français et progressif il est
familialiser et il est conjugue alizés
j'aurai trois questions est ce que votre
prélèvement à la source est simple non
le contribuable devra toujours faire une
déclaration de revenus avec une
régularisation l'année suivante les
crédits d'impôts ne sont donc plus pris
en compte l'année en cours ce qui
inquiète les professionnels du bâtiment
pour l'année 2010 est vous devez
pratiquer une amnistie fiscale avec une
année blanche en 2017
est-ce que c'est neutre pour les ménages
non surtout pas c'est une avance de
trésorerie à l'état elle est donc
pénalisante pour le pouvoir d'achat des
ménages
plusieurs millions de contribuables vont
voir leurs revenus chuter en janvier
2018 ce qui dans le contexte d'hyper
sensibilité à l'impôt va encore nuire
aux nécessaires climat de confiance
entre le citoyen et l'administration
enfin pour les entreprises est-ce que
c'est logique une complexité
supplémentaire alors que vous aviez
parlé d'un choc de simplification les
entreprises devront assurer la
confidentialité des données fiscales et
de leur transmission
enfin les entreprises seront
l'interlocuteur entre leurs salariés
donc vos contribuable et
l'administration fiscale est ce
réellement le rôle
monsieur le ministre
ne considérez vous pas que la facture
fiscale de votre quinquennat est déjà
suffisamment salé comme cela merci la
palette à monsieur christian équerre
secrétaire d'état chargé du budget et
des comptes publics
merci monsieur le président messieurs
les députés madame la députée
marie-christine dalloz
ce n'est pas parce que la droite a été
incapable de mettre en oeuvre une
réforme qu'elle a si souvent annoncé que
madame la députée il faut énoncer des
contre vérités
je vais répondre précisément vos
questions mais nous aurons jeudi et
vendredi l'occasion d'en débattre avec
celles et ceux qui voudront bien
s'adonner au débat mais madame la
députée vous nous interroger sur les
crédits et les réductions d'impôts bien
sûr qu'ils seront maintenus
tous les crédits et réductions d'impôts
acquis au titre de l'année 2010 est
seront comme d'habitude perçus l'année
suivante et certains même vos
participera aux débats seront perçus
même par anticipation nous aurons
reviendrons il ya des travaux en cours
sur ce point vous nous interroger sur
l'année de transition mais oui les
choses sont claires les revenus
ordinaires
or les revenus exceptionnels de l'année
2017 ne seront pas dans l'assiette de
l'impôt sur le revenu il y aura pour les
contribuables en 2017 l'impôt payé sur
l'année 2016 et en 2018 l'année d'impôts
payés sur les revenus de 2018
il n'y a là aucune anticipation il y à
une année où les revenus des salariés
des pensionnés ne seront pas assujettis
à l'impôt sur le revenu alors vous
parlez de comparaison avec d'autres pays
mais il ya bien d'autres pays où l'impôt
et progressif ou l'impôt et familialiser
et où le prélèvement à la source a lieu
alors je crois que cette réforme est
souhaitée par l'ensemble des français
toutes les études d'opinion le
entre très majoritairement et je crois
qu'il n'y a pas là de combat d'arrière
garde
amenez nous sommes ouverts au travail et
cette réforme sera je l'espère mais
récit